a recenter no oh cool I used to this
side you want to switch
no no tattoos oh hey hey guys I'm Ryan
right
hey guys I'm Mary Jane Watson we're
gonna be discussing a video today Kevin
fig talks about the spider-man deal now
for guys out there and girls who don't
know Kevin Vegas he's the president of
Marvel pictures yeah no big deal Marvel
Studios do you yeah we're mainly here
today because seven Webb heads the go to
channel about anything spider-man
related tweeted Sally and the real
rejects you should totally do reaction
video to this guy's you know what so
shout out to you seven Webb heads hey
your seat up hey they're gonna fight it
hey cool it with this death penalty
middle bun yellow but a champion don't
they know we're gonna do you bone up but
in May last jump that yellow
sizzling it's a movie ended up here the
GPO netted a bottle he was feeling today
no Meah Meah shangela me in the Regla I
mean I don't know Hey
I didn't know until like how with yeah I
was like what's going on here whoever
did this is amazing okay so that
confused the hell out of me but now I'm
so glad we watched it so yeah they just
like decided to put all the information
in oh so it's the it's a story story
that he already told what they just put
different dialogue subtitles in Kevin
Feige hasn't actually come up with a
video but someone decided to like and
just put all the information with this
video that was really brilliant that was
but the reason why I was so caught
off-guard by it like I could understand
if a real if a rejects from the channel
like sent this to us as a joke to
reactive in the segment seven women send
this I thought it was like a legit video
this way yeah I know everyone was coming
to watch it so I thought this was like a
serious video about Kevin fig finally
talking about spiral the information I
finally figured out as a joke is first
of all I was like I don't think the
president of more
we'll just be finished when he would say
like names like Iron Man Andrew Garfield
they weren't even in the Hispanic accent
it wasn't it didn't match up and I was
totally into God that was a funny skit
that was really good whoever did that
it's clever because it I like deceitful
skits that make you go like this is real
then wait a minute is he like and it
just gets more absurd and more absurd
with a laughing like that was a one joke
premise that I thought was really funny
actually usually one joke skits I get
bored of fast but that's pretty funny
timing of it what the things he was
saying with the things that were typed
were it was perfect and it's actually
the best way to get notified about the
information on spider Lu if you want to
get in a fun update you just watch this
video take this video and put any sort
of news in it no watch it just man I got
this spider-man tattoo on my face
already because I thought this was gonna
be like a big spider video waiting seven
he has seven web heads thank you so much
I'm happy about it like we both call
spider-man I thought I was gonna come my
web head out you know what I mean I
thought was gonna shoot like seven web
heads out by an awesome orgasm of
spider-man information but no I mean he
looks like he was having a good time
what do you look like seven web heads
guy she was your [ __ ] face yeah you
should do a response video to this yeah
show us your face he wants to know what
he wants to see the deceit you're a dick
anyway yeah thanks all you guys plus
seven web as time as this video is out
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out salamander Sally's channel
a lot of fun stuff on there and if you
want to actually see us discuss these
videos there's two links in the
description box where we have a video
talking about all the rumors then we
have a video talking about after
everything was confirmed so you can get
our full insight on already called
everything and it all happened it all
happened it all happened we predicted a
lot of things didn't happen but a lot
did happen
yeah but that is also a big thanks to
seven mopeds and his amazing information
on his channel I don't understand how he
gets all of it maybe there's like a
secret like CIA thing for just Marvel
and he's a part of it how does he get
all that information that quickly do you
think he has woman dress up like a
spider girl so and then he [ __ ] them in
a spider-man outfit I don't know but if
you had the opportunity he totally fit I
would totally do that I'd be so good to
be honest like I've always wanted to
roleplay in Spider it'll be a great
dessert did I go too far